[Music]
gong has fought a lot of enemies over
the years and even though most of them
are either
the humans that capture him or the
fighter aircraft that shoot him down
from the top of the empire state
building
but there have been creatures as well
that has battled the giant ape from time
to time
a majority of the big creatures and
monsters that commerce fought and
defeated are reptiles
but some are squishy with tentacles and
also mecca's
the big ape has been undefeated and the
only ones that has brought him down
are well smaller apes us humans with our
technology and wits
so in this video we will showcase to you
the 11 monster enemies of kong
that he has fought over the course of
many films and comics as well
number one tyrannosaurus rex seen in the
first
1933 movie itself this dinosaur is found
in skull island
it is one of the only creatures capable
of challenging gorm and in fighting with
him
this t-rex is 12.3 meters long or 40
feet
and stands 3.6 meters or 12 feet tall at
the hips
but the really early model of dinosaurs
standing more upright than later models
this t-rex was 20 feet tall at the head
in the movie king kong heard
the screams of anne darrow and rushed to
find her being hunted by a t-rex
he then battled the dinosaur and later
overcame him with much struggle and
snapped its jaw
this was the first time people saw two
giant monsters fight on screen
some even thought it was real number two
the giant octopus
this kaiju was seen in the 1962 film
king kong vs godzilla
it is a cephalopod kaiju that was 100
feet long
or 30 meters and had eight very long
tentacles reminiscent of modern day
octopus species
but with more durable height and with a
tougher leathery skin along with his
eyes on top of its bulbous head
its nickname was the devil of the sea
and this monster crawled up a show on
pharaoh island
and attacked a village the humans fought
back with shotguns and spears but to no
avail
the kong appeared and started throwing
things at the octopus
it then got hold of kong but after a
short struggle kong overcame it and
threw two large boulders at it
sending it retreating back into the
ocean number three the gorosaurus
this creature is yet another dinosaur
that fought kong but the difference
between it and the t-rex is that this is
a kaiju
and not an extinct dinosaur that once
roamed the earth its design
stood upright with a stale dragging on
the ground and possess a large head with
muscular legs
and short arms this kaiju was 115 feet
tall
with a hundred feet long tail thus
totaling 65 meters or 215 feet long
this sketchy was seen on mondo island in
the 1967 movie king kong escapes
as it was trying to eat susan watson yet
another damsel in distress
and what does kong do when he hears her
screaming
he comes to the rescue and defeats the
gorosaurus
number 4 mechanic gong in the 1967 movie
king kong escapes
there was a robot version of kong called
mechanic gong that was built by doctor
who
to dig for element x but later doctor
who hypnotizes the real kong to dig for
the element
and kong eventually breaks out of his
trance and swims to tokyo
battling the 20 meter or 65 feet tall
mechanic gong on top of tokyo tower
mechanicong falls to his destruction
from the top of the tower
mirroring kong's demise in the original
film this robot aside from its great
strength
it has high intensity lights in its eyes
it can be used to blind opponents
although not as agile as the real core
mechanical possesses greater endurance
and modified to carry explosives number
five the vastatosaurus rex
in a 2005 movie kong faced up against
the v-rex which is an evolved version of
the t-rex
and has developed many unique features
over the course of
65 million years but it still retains
several
recognizable similarities to their
cretaceous cousins
the rexes are 50 feet long or 15 meters
and have very large heads that evolved
over time to be thicker and bulkier
giving them extra protection and its
overall leathery height
reduces physical injury from hunting if
his choice of prey was smaller or even
bigger than itself
its gaping mark was its main tool for
hunting filled with very large
teeth that were constantly being regrown
if they fell off
kong faced off against three of these in
the movie and killed the last one by
snapping his jaw like he did with the
t-rex and the gorosaurus
number six the maya squid this monster
scientifically named the gigantis
levipus
are also known as the my squid the river
devil red devil or river monster
is a 90 to 110 feet long species of
giant freshwater cephalopod
that is found on skull island the animal
appeared in the 2017 movie gong skull
island
and they are rare solitary ambush
predators that lurk in the lakes of
skull island for
unsuspecting prey they hunt by waiting
until their prey have come close enough
the maya squid can stealthily move
through the water to avoid being spotted
for most prey
and predators one of these quits fought
against gong in the movie but later
became seafood for the giant ape
number seven the skull crawlers these
creatures are the main villains of the
2017
kong skull island movie and were
responsible for killing kong's family
and his entire species they are large
reptilian creatures with two long full
limbs and no
hind limbs and long prehensile
serpentine tails
they are long and slender but with very
muscular and sturdy bodies their
appearances are noticeably skeletal
particularly their torsos
and their heads while most of these
monsters are way smaller than kong and
possess
little or no threat at all to him the
big one however is capable of killing
kong
and it was almost 200 feet long and 90
feet tall however kong killed it by
ripping out its guts from its mouth
number eight camazotz next we have
camazotz which is also scientifically
named as titanos camazotz
and this one is a giant bat like dai
kaiju created by legendary pitchers for
the monsterverse
it is proposed to appear in an upcoming
comic book in which he will fight kong
before the events of godzilla vs kong
not much is known about kamazos but it
is rumored to be
a mayan bad god associated with knight
death and sacrifice
his name was likely chosen due to
camzad's strong resemblance to a bat
and due to his god-like status as a
titan capable of challenging kong
it is also possible that camazotz
himself was the mayan bad god
number 9 godzilla yes of course we have
the g-man
on this list and he had already fought
against kong in the 1962 movie king kong
vs godzilla and will
sadly he lost the fight although some
say it was a draw
but the results could be either way the
g-man in this movie was 164 feet tall
and a bit taller than kong
the king of the monsters had his atomic
breath and all the physical powers that
were associated with him
during that time and at first he almost
killed kong but a giant ape got a power
up from a thunderstrike
a lightning strike and actually became
the most electrifying ape in kaiju
entertainment
if you smell er that is a bit too much
nevertheless they both are getting a
rematch this coming summer
may 21. number 10 the giant boa
the giant bow is the only monster along
with king kong that appears in the 1976
remake
unlike previous versions kong never
battles with any dinosaurs in the 1976
movie and his fight
with the giant bow as the only monster
in the movie despite being in the film
for a short time
it is assumed that the giant snake is a
great predator that kills without
remorse
the giant bower also showed itself to be
determined constricting around kong
to crush him seeing that the 1976 kong
was 42 feet tall
or around 13 meters the boa coiled
around
him therefore making it slang more than
twice that of kong maybe around 100 feet
or so number 11 the giant sea serpent
this giant sea serpent only has a short
appearance in the movie king kong
escapes
when the film central character susan
watson and her companions
are attempting to leave mondo island the
giant sea serpent rises out of the water
and approaches their craft
on the shore king kong concerned with
the safety of susan then throws a bowler
at a serpent to distract it while susan
watson and her companions escape the
serpent
king kong goes off into the water and is
attacked by the giant sea serpent
who attempts to constrict calm after a
brief skirmish kong frees himself from
the giant sea serpent's grasp
and tosses him back into the water so
before we end the topic
do check out our teespring store and
grab a monsterverse titan mark or two
we also have teas hoodies pillows and
phone cases as well as masks
with our designs and logos do tell us
your thoughts on the matter
and so with that we come to the end of
this list of giant monster enemies of
com
thanks mine queuers and for the new
viewers do hit that subscribe button for
more videos and smash that notification
bell
for regular updates